[Music]
please don't get involved
what is poppin thickies it is july 18th
monday morning in calabasas just cracked
a fresh cold dc
not a sponsor
one day
one day man we'll get there chin we're
young bucks dude we're so young man
we're just getting younger too dude it's
cool
you know just two young guys yeah
looking swaggy today dude thanks bro
matching zingle
can you step up your fashion game dude
yeah i get it
i get it joggers the dope kicks why not
yeah i'm not mad at that outfit at all
cinch thanks bro
uh your boy is fresh off the plane from
fort wayne indiana
never been out there
um
i would definitely go back to fort wayne
some of these uh the coolest thing about
my gig is i get to travel all over and
experience all these different cities
and towns and stuff like that and fort
wayne is a
big city uh
fort wayne is uh
it's like a small community and they're
just like they appreciate you going
there
and uh not a ton to do not a ton to do
not gonna lie to you guys some great
restaurants the local uh
uh i think triple a baseball team the
tin
hats or tin cats 10 hats the tin hats
your boy wore the jersey out there
um the club is called the summit comedy
club same owners as brickstown comedy
club in oklahoma city and they own the
spokane washington comedy club um
and they own tacoma and they're just
they're great man
um but when i was out there
on what was it friday
uh i get
yeah fri i'm sorry thursday
this young man named jacob this young
man named jacob i think he's 22 23 years
old he's very young
but he works for at security at the
helium in indianapolis which is a newer
club helium club
and uh he sat in traffic and he drove
three hours just to meet me and come to
the show
and then he stayed after to introduce
himself and you can tell you know he's a
young kid and he's
i i i don't think he struggled with
confidence he's just a bit of an
introvert you know and uh he was saying
how big of a deal is for him to even
introduce himself and all this stuff and
they told me he's a comic and how hard
is for him to get stage time and i said
dude you drove three hours just to say
hi to me because yeah man and i go into
your comic he goes yeah he's telling me
how you can't get up how long have you
been doing he goes a little over two and
a half years i go very cool man i said
well um you want to do a a set a friday
you want to you know you want to come do
sets and he's like what he's like hell
yeah i'm like all right dude anybody
who's willing to drive six hours to
introduce themselves
um and take that chance you know i'm
gonna give you a shot man so
now don't get it twisted we posted a a
video of this kid doing the damn thing
and he had a hot five minutes i asked
him and usually whenever you asked like
new york comics like how much time you
got they're like 30 minutes you're like
okay you don't have 30. but this kid was
like literally
one second past five and i'm screwed
he's like i have
five
minutes nothing more nothing less five
minutes dude i'm like well you're honest
this is a good sign
i've done this before and obviously i
don't we don't blast it out all the time
i you know i always like to give people
chances because so many people took
chances on me so i try to pay it forward
sometimes it doesn't work out like this
we've had it where it goes awful and the
person lied and they haven't been doing
comedy that long or
um it's just they're cussing a lot or
they have just bad material whatever but
this kid you know he he works hard and
tries to get up when he can and he
crushed it man straight up five minutes
crushed it you just see after that first
show mark was that his confidence went
through the roof man he was like so
appreciative and you know he just he's
just a good dude man he's a really
really nice kid trying to find his way
and works just a regular job just works
you know a nine to five or a good job in
the security at night at the helium and
then uh hopefully this gives him a
little boost because he absolutely
crushed it uh you guys can farm his
name's jacob kendall 69. i don't know
what has that 69 in the end
um yeah so it's uh he
really
wow dang that's cool
yeah so it is you can follow him at
j-a-k-o-b-k-e-n-d-a-l-l-69
um that's super cool of you to do man i
love i love seeing stuff like this yeah
just a really really good dude man
really really good dude
that's the thing everyone around there
was cool man everyone was cool there
that's uh tin caps you asked me we're
rocking the the uh
the single a triple a jersey there and
there's mark snuggled i know what is
that more waitresses
just grabbing her by her big um
brazier
um
yeah he's such a good dude man he's such
a good kid and hopefully this gives him
the boost to freaking keep it going you
know that's what you want to do man
because you know he's had a tough go
he's a tough go and um he was great and
then also
um the other guys named tyler
tyler was it tyler right alex eakin
that's right alex eakin
alex was uh he's been coming out of
seven or nine years but he's like the
you know he's the go-to comedian in fort
wayne he rides and dies for fort wayne
to like shout out the freaking area code
and [ __ ] you know um but he you know
he's a he's a veteran he was he was
great man he was also our tour guide out
there showed us he couldn't be more
excited to show us around fort wayne he
was all about it such a good dude gifts
right at the airport at freaking
4 a.m i was uh your boy stayed up 24
hours first time i've ever done it since
college when i did in college i got very
sick stayed up straight up 24 hours
and made it back to um
you know
get back man
i was just reading that comment that's
cool uh the guy put i put uh 24 hours i
haven't done that since college dad life
schedule is probably just caffeine
strange thoughts feeling your brain
right now at least you made it you ain't
lying dude my uh my two-year-old is
obsessed
with the the car show in malibu he wakes
up and just pop a car show pop a car
show i'm like it's on sunday dude monday
through saturday sunday morning every
single it's all he talks about so if we
miss it he's gonna be furious
so uh had that six a.m flight out of
fort wayne and we got stage around one
something and then we came back and was
just like all right well we're gonna be
picked up in three hours you know
your body's just like yeah
i'm gonna give you anxiety about missing
your freaking flight let's just stay up
we have i was uh fueled by
a ton of coffee a ton of coffee and your
boy made it through the
through the day i made it through the
day head to the all-star game tonight
homer and derby taking the little man
uh the all-star game is in los angeles
uh anybody else have anxiety about a big
events with those uh active shooters
going on here's the thing about that
obviously the media and when it happens
it's awful but the chances of it
happening are not good you know they're
not good at all but
i don't know this stuff freaks me out as
a dad you know it's first thing i think
of when someone's like hey you want to
go to the home run derby time bring your
son like so many people man you know i
feel like those places are probably the
safest so nothing really happens in
those places yeah i'm the least famous
guy on the field so they're they're
protecting like freaking
you know john legend so i think i'll
just run behind him i feel like i'll
just grab my kid i'll toss my kid john
legend like protect yourself you know
so we'll see that stuff stresses me out
but uh yeah busy week dude we got a big
announcement coming for thick boy i'll
let you know we can announce it this is
uh it's gonna be cool so a big
announcement coming for thick boy
studios
and then uh
wednesday night i will be at the
hollywood improv shop and friends um
it's the 10 p.m show we're doing the
late show because i hate doing stand-up
when it's bright outside so um that is
the 10 p.m show at the hollywood improv
it's trevor wallace eric griffin anthony
jeselnik
and
a guy that rhymes with bis babia
so um yeah with some big dogs man it's
gonna be really fun can't wait and then
thursday your boy heads on out uh
driving down to uh san diego literally i
shot my first special for a reason it's
one of my first places if not my
favorite do stand up san diego laugh
factory the heart of downtown san diego
i'm at the laugh factory thursday friday
saturday and that is this week get
tickets at thickboy.com san diego come
support your boy in the summer
trash panda tour so come get some then
baltimore is august 4th through the 6th
we have the one night in chicago at the
den theater there friday night uh i
think 7 30 show in chicago and the next
day on the 27th is the thick mudder so
go to toughmudder.com on the 10 a.m on
the 27th in chicago come run with the
thick boy squad limited capacity there
as well so um make sure you get you some
right now and come run the the
tough mudder with the thick boy crew man
it's gonna be good old time
take a little break kids taking a break
so we have breaks i'll be insane san
diego this thursday friday saturday
laugh factory san diego get your tickets
at thickboy.com
but i will be in san diego perform at
night but during the day
man we have one heck of a ufc fight
night action it unfolds in the octagon
in london this saturday get your own win
with draftkings that's right the daily
fantasy partner of the ufc the official
daily fantasy part of the ufc feel the
thrill of every jab kick takedown while
you play for your share of over one
million dollars in total prizes playing
daily fantasy mma is simple draft your
lineup of six fighters while staying
under the salary cap and rack up points
for strikes advances kos and more with a
stacked fight card this saturday plus a
shot to claim your share at over one
million dollars in prizes you'll
experience the ufc fight night london
like never before draftkings is safe
secure reliable best of all you can
deposit withdraw your cash whenever you
want don't miss a shot to take down
stacks of cash during ufc fight night
london this saturday
download the draftkings app right now
use the promo code shop show that's
s-c-h-a-u-b show to play fancy mma for
your share at over one million dollars
in total prizes that's promo code shop
show this saturday at draftkings the
official daily fantasy partner of ufc
eligibility restriction supply see
draftkings.com for details
hey man uh you guys are sleeping on
awful mattresses and you're like man i
don't get it man i just i can't get
right it doesn't feel good i've been
sleeping on the same mattress since i
was a kid oh where'd you get it just
your normal mattress store well listen
that mattress is built for every joe
schmoe out there you need a little helix
sleep that's right helix sleep they make
custom mattresses just for your thick
body all you got to do is take the quiz
it takes two minutes and then they match
you up with the perfect mattress
just for your side sleeper back sleeper
tummy sleeper you sleep hot cold helix
sleep they got you covered man they make
the mattress that you need in your life
that's not built for every joe schmoe
out there it's built for you helix was
even awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2019 2020 by gq and
wired magazine i have them at my house i
can't get rid of my in-laws can't get
rid of my friends i was like oh they
just love me nope they love my mattress
because they get a great night rest all
right just go to helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they will match you with your perfect
mattress and they will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free all right they even
pick it up if you don't love it but
you're well so don't worry about that
helix is offering you guys up to 200 off
all mattress orders and free pillows for
all the listeners and viewers of the
shop show go to helixsleep.com
that's helixleep.com shop for up to 200
off now let's get into some fights dude
that's why you guys are here let's get
in some freaking fights you had fights
over the weekend
and this one i was able to watch from
top to bottom because uh it was started
at i think
oh 11 a.m 11 a.m pacific you know so i
was on the east coast time in fort wayne
which is where it's east coast time
right that weird that's surprising
we're three hours ahead of you guys
very strange i don't realize where fort
winds have been i didn't realize it's
like not far from chicago it's not far
from ohio detroit like so many people
came from all these spots i'm like what
is that like a two day drive like um
hour and a half i'm like we're an hour
and a half away from chicago like yeah
dude like oh my god
i had no clue
we're gonna post my bit on uh rudy this
week uh because fort wayne is like
i think 60 miles from the university of
notre dame so
i do the green room diaries and i write
a joke in the green room and then
perform it at the top of every show just
for that certain city and then we post
those for you guys so this week it's
it's indiana but it's based off notre
dame and the movie rudy and that will be
out very soon it's a fun one team's
editing it together now it's a fun one
fruity sees he's gonna be best what can
you do uh but yeah i was able to watch
all the fights because it's at such a
weird time it didn't make sense because
this one was weird to me i i'm curious
what the viewership was like fighting at
that time but it's in i think long
island
and you have two mexican fighters in the
main event in long island
i mean you could have put it anywhere i
mean gonna put it
in arizona texas california anywhere
else anywhere with latins but
the crowd was loud and i think it was
the biggest gate ever in that arena the
most tickets ever sold so
the ufc is like shut your pie hole like
no doubt you're doing well all right um
fights were good man fights were good um
i'll tell you what and i told you guys
this last week but dustin jacoby man i
think he's won nine in a row now um this
kid is a problem
he's a colorado boy trains out of
factory x and uh
you know stand-up is off the chain off
the chain so he uh
he's interesting because this is his
second stint in the ufc his first one he
he lost both fights he lost another
colorado product and chris camozzi who i
came up with shout out to chris camozzi
he lost uh two fights in the ufc and
then went we're all set buddy so then he
goes to
hoosiers fight club that must have been
a disaster for you and then he goes the
cage fury world series of fighting um
you know he fights david brancher that
fight loses that i think it was the ccw
titan shot to like manhole in sight then
goes to bellator loses uh to
then loses john salter it's a tough
fight
beltron goes we're all set he goes all
right cool i'm going to scl74
king of sparta in golden colorado shout
out to golden colorado great bear out
there coors coors
ever heard of it coors bear comes out of
there guys
so he goes there he fights cody east
cody east is a greg jackson's product
and he uh his brother's tyler east
now i think uh tyler is dead and i think
cody's in prison currently but i used to
train with those two savages with jon
jones back in the day
those guys make jon jones
look like mother teresa they were out of
control i once had to spar tyler east on
cocaine and you've never seen anybody
with better cardio you've also seen
you've never seen more spinning back
fist when spinning back elbows during a
sparring session he was trying to take
my head off and i get down like oh my
god that guy's cardio is [ __ ] nuts
when he's lance armstrong coach was like
he's on something different my man i was
like yo protein i was just so naive i'm
like what what acai bowl no you'll
figure it out one day your boy figured
it out and i'm 39 years old and i was
like oh
wish i had some just kidding um so he
goes on to fight cody's right
he gets one win and then he gets on dana
white's contender series he gets on
there he fights ty flores and it's a
good fight it's a good fight again his
background is kickboxing he's a tip of
the spare uh skill-wise kickboxer he
fights ty flores uh and wins in dana
white contender series and they give him
a shot they go and there's a little you
know dana white contender series really
isn't for older guys like who's who have
tried for the the younger bucks or guys
who are trying to make your name and get
into the ufc it's a much better feeder
system than the ultimate fighter not
even close i don't even know why they
still do the ultimate fighter nine
people watching it's very expensive to
make
but espn's like we'll take it so um
you know they give them the pass which i
was surprised by thank god they did
because i've always been a fan of they
give them they give them the pass
right and imagine this guy he's older
he's not young i won't say he's like 36.
uh look him up chin 34 34. you know what
i'm saying 34 fort morgan colorado he's
not he's not young but they give him a
chance
and thank god they did
this guy goes on to win
including the dana white contender
series one two three four five six
seven fights in a row in the ufc
imagine if they never give them a shot
imagine if they went just too old man
we're good
then jacoby's entire
life changes dude but now dude he's won
seven and he's a father good dude for
not like dedicated to
freaking mixed martial arts how does uh
was a college quarterback i think juco
but still college quarterback uh i think
also a basketball player had division
one offers decided you know fight so
he's
super gifted athletically um you know
seven in a row in the ufc
at the light heavyweight division you
know so and and they're not getting like
toss-ups either like he's playing tough
guys like that da um zhong was a monster
yeah he was he was a mod he looked good
too was he korean chance he's [ __ ]
big dude wasn't he big yeah undefeated
yeah undefeated and like not the best
matchup from this
supposed fight previously and then
finally they made it happen this time
what's interesting about him is
jay's like what is it the biggest queen
you've ever seen i said him or the guy
who plays for is the uh guy who plays
for anaheim korean two or is he japanese
oh that japanese is his job
he's [ __ ] you know super tall yeah
but that uh that uh
um
i'm telling jay this i'm like think
about he's 6'4 he cuts 205 he probably
watched at 2 30. dime piece
bodied up too good looking dude got a
little confident hands down you got ko
super that's his biggest problem double
jab right hands
your boy gets 50k
so uh jacob's gonna get um he's getting
a top ten guy now like he's he's there
man
you know
his his wrestling grappling is gonna
blow your hair back but if they give him
the right matchups just like anybody
unless your karmaroosman there's you
know there's those elite guys who can do
everything but
if the ufc wants his story to be told
they can give him the match-ups to get
him to the title shot
and i hope they do
i really hope they do and that's what's
going on with the main event this
weekend ufc london which we'll get to
it's all about who the ufc wants to be
champ because there's
way less
um
challenges for certain guys depending on
matchups depend on what the ufc wants to
do and they gave both the guys the worst
matchups we'll get to that um so miami
p's uh justin jacoby after hearing that
story hope you guys are more of a fan of
justin coe hope he's on your radar and
hopefully they quit putting him on the
god damn prelims
he's had some decisions but the dude is
stand up wise dude technical [ __ ] great
story great father monster dude he's fun
to watch
that even the right matchup he's going
to light you on fire
uh the one that broke my heart was my
boy jack shore yeah jack george we love
king listening alumni we he always
supports us we support him he's such a
talented kid uh they give him ricky
simone a lot of people thoughts to me
you know fight the night good fight it
was a bummer to see you know but also
i'm a ricky simone fan if you know ricky
was the one guy who had the theo von
mullett for a long time cuts his hair
kind of like that pseudo 80s like
you know kurt russell you know
escape la vibe going on but he's he
looks so much stronger than jack short i
know
he just like like you know he just
looked
like he's there yeah now that
don't feel too bad for jack short like
jack shorts young is all town in the
world he just has to go back to the
drawing board you know that that uh arm
triangle choke was uh pretty savage so
you know ricky simone's been doing it a
lot longer he's more of ufc vet you know
he'll get there he'll get there so uh
for for for ricky simone he's just a
veteran you know it's his time for jack
short head up brother head up and that
is one two three four five in a row for
him
and uh he
you know
before he stumbled upon two losses to
europe and rob font which is nothing to
hang your head about and also rob font
was fight of the night
he's beat some [ __ ] monsters dude
monsters this was a very tough matchup
for jack short where he's at you know
but jack shore it just shows you where
the ufc thinks he's at because
you know he's he was undefeated he was
he went into the fight 16-0 obviously
lost this one um i would i thought this
was too much too soon i would like to
slow it down a little bit you know reese
simone's been there with your favorite
he's beat top top echelon guys
you know i would have liked him to slow
down a little bit for him but it shows
you where
jack shore is at and if i know anything
about jack shore and this happens with
all great fighters
is you have these speed bumps to get you
ready
for the push to get a title shot like
this will get him ready this is what he
needed certain guys need that like if
you look at francis and ghana over stipe
the first time francis thought he was
just going to walk through him as he's
walked into the octagon he looks at dan
and goes get the private jet writing day
like what the [ __ ] no private jet i
think it's molly whopped right so but
think how much better francis has gotten
from that fight it's going so much
better ridiculous
um so head up jack short we love you
here man
um what else do we have going on you
actually have the great comeback fight
everyone talks about it was good poor
misha tate it's a tough pill to swallow
off your misha tate at her age you know
lauren murphy did the goddamn thing
showed out uh shane burgos got the job
done
uh matt schnell is the one everyone's
talking about we're just getting just
[ __ ]
there's like a rudy's awesome comment
i'm saying yeah great comeback come back
you know come back of the year for sure
your boy jingling's back killed it huh
yeah good for him man i thought his
confidence was [ __ ] but he was like
hold the fort and beat the [ __ ] out of
the muslim um
uh you know for misha tay and michelle
waterson there's very uh common things
going on here you know they're both
older later in their career
losses at this stage is a huge setback
you know
um
i think for michelle waterson
you know she's really an atom weight
she's like for the division amanda limos
is a savage such a savage so
they're not doing michelle any favors
here man they're just not um you know so
for misha and michelle waterson
i think the love for the game as if they
still want to do it um depending how
much do you see is paying them but as
far as a championship run it should be
tough for both of them now very very
tough
and the main event
um you know yaya and brian ortega
they uh
they obviously have so much respect for
each other and there's a friendly
relationship there which
i think hurt them which we'll get to but
they both vowed to you know show their
true mexican bloodlines and fight like
mexicans and they did they came out
firing um prior to after a fight wanted
to say he was winning the entire fight
until his shoulder popped out i didn't
see it that way i thought on the feet
brian was in a little bit of trouble i
thought there was a speeded huge speed
advantage for a yayir he was landing i
know brian ortega has a chin
but you only have so much gin you know
if to do that for five rounds can be
very tough and he's been through some
wars and which is why he's had all these
injuries and which is why he's in fought
nine months and he has these long
layoffs um and for yair you just look
like the fresher fighter and then you
know obviously the
if you are on brian ortega's side which
i am 99.999
of the time
you know it was going his way as far as
getting the takedown and that's where
the fight starts
but then he gets that take down right
and yair goes to an arm bar
yeah he goes to an arm bar and they you
know they stop the fight and everyone's
like yo run it back brianna would take
you hurt his shoulder i text the group
and we only get the time of it i don't
know which experts in the mma game i
think kenny florian might be the only
one saying this
um as soon as that happened i text the
thick boy chat and you only get the time
as soon as that happened before they
even gave out the
the
decision um from the from the commission
and the judges and all that i said oh
that's a submission that was a
submission
there was a submission victory for yahoo
rodriguez
and what's going on in the game now is i
don't know who the analysts were i think
it was anik dc
and
felder yeah
but i think if you had more of a jiu
jitsu perspective
rogan has a very good judicial
perspective dominic cruz
those guys would have noticed what was
going on
because if you notice
the reason this should be labeled as
submission victory
yaya rodriguez and don't get twisted in
any facet nobody loves brian or taking
more than i do i love i came up with
brian i knew brian you know i cornered
brian before his fight in the ufc when
he fought in some small show i cornered
him um i loved brian take it me and him
did camps together i [ __ ] absolutely
loved that kid we did that awful movie
together with shia labeouf okay
um and he almost beat shia labeouf up
but
you know i i told my brother you know
what hopefully yahya's not so friendly
with brian that he goes oh yeah let's
run it back that's such a shame
because if i'm yair
you have
about 30 seconds when they hand you that
mic to paint the narrative and that
narrative goes worldwide and once you do
that that's your moment if you miss it
it's over you can say in the press
conference it's not as powerful if you
do it right when dc hands you the mic
you change the entire narrative
because my narrative if i'm his team
goes hold on that was submission because
think about
it if brian did that because he's so
well known for his jitsu submission
skills you know we all think he's the
best in the division
um or some would even say the best
submission artist in the ufc you know
charles oliveira would have an argument
for that because his finishes but as far
as straight up technical jiu-jitsu his
name's t city comes under hunter gracie
you know he's basically born in the
jujitsu gym i think if ortega was on the
bottom got this uh people that's a
submission but because it's yair do it
to brian ortega who is a jiu jitsu
expert we go oh
brian's shoulder must have blown out
well let's talk about that if you break
it down
what caused the shoulder to blow out now
brian ortega is coming off two shoulder
surgeries and he's he's because of his
fighting style and he goes so hard on
the pain during training camp
you know he's rough on his body so
you're getting these long layoffs from
brian ortega
do i think his shoulder would have
popped out if he didn't have shoulder
issues in the shoulder surgeries no
but he does
so what made his shoulder pop out did it
pop out from and we've seen this before
like korean zombie who throws a punch
and his shoulder throws out and they
gotta stop the fight well that's on
korean zombie nobody caused that korean
zombie decided to do an action that led
to him not being able to fight
in this case and yahya and brian ortega
the action that caused brian ortega to
tap out and stop fighting was an action
of offense from yaya rodriguez
the action of the arm bar which the
initial setup of the arm bar
is is in the legs it's in the legs that
provides the pressure so you can't
because the the number one defense to uh
defend an armbar is to stack them stack
them and lift up and get your arm out of
there but you control their posture with
your legs heavy on your legs when my
sons learn it now to do that
they tell you it's like claws you're
really heavy on the legs so they can't
raise up and get out of the submission
well yair's pressure was so hard and the
way if you look at the iron bar it was
almost uh kimura-like so a kimura is
giving me obviously the elbows in
trouble there but all the pressure's on
that shoulder
and that's an offensive action from yaya
rodriguez because brian ortega has bad
shoulders it caused that shoulder to pop
out which technically that would be a
submission it'd be a shoulder submission
but because and i'm not saying dc and
anik and paul felder don't know jujitsu
but at the highest level you would know
that in that compromising permission
position that brian ortega was in
there's so much pressure on his shoulder
that technically would be a submission
but it's not
very
common so you just go oh he fell back
and hurt his shoulder i went oh that's a
submission
i think most jiu jitsu practitioners or
people that are black belts on jutsu
would consider that a submission
but the average friend is oh brian uh
hurt his shoulder fell back
but why did he why did he blow out his
shoulder why did the fight stop again if
brian threw his shoulder out when
they're in the middle of the octagon and
he does and he misses and hits air do an
offensive position and throws his
shoulder out
stop the fight through his shoulder out
that's on pride
the only reason
brian's shoulder came out of socket and
he was unable to continue the fight was
due to an offensive submission tactic by
yahir rodriguez which to me is clearly a
submission
whether he taps there falls back and
taps it doesn't matter the only reason
that fight was stopped because gaire
rodriguez got brian ortega in an armbar
and because you guys didn't see him tap
because his arm was gonna break which is
in most cases he tapped because the
pressure was so intense it blew out his
shoulder
which would be a submission
right away
so for people oh this is a horrible
ending i'm like
no
this is if i'm me i hear i get on that
mic and go got that listen all respect
to brian ortega
i can't believe i submitted him dana i
need 50 000. i just submitted brian
ortega t city black belt dude
the champ couldn't do it matt holloway
couldn't do it i just finished brian
ortega t city with submission where's my
50k bonus then call out the champ get on
there
where you out vodka nowski i just
submitted brian to you you couldn't
finish him what's up bro
boom we're off to the races that's the
narrative but instead
he's humble oh yeah we can run it back
man we'll see what happens and then
that's the narrative nobody's talking
about this now i'm like oh you missed
such a key opportunity and you're saying
talking [ __ ]
that is exactly what happened there's no
other argument
there's absolutely no argument i'm i'm
not saying i'm gonna end all be all here
i'm telling you man
it's very evident the only reason that
fight was stopped is by an offensive
movement
of yay rodriguez locking in an arm bar
and because it wasn't traditionally
finished with pressure on the elbows
pressure on the on the shoulder people
go oh brian blew his shoulder out
huh well why was his shoulder being
compromised because yaya rodriguez
locked in a savage arm bar and the
armbar the angle was so weird it's
almost like a camaro where there's so
much pressure on that [ __ ] shoulder
bryant has bad shoulders
who wouldn't take advantage of that
that's something you would even consider
during training camp we know he has two
bad shoulders you lock in the submission
you crank on that [ __ ] shoulder
i don't get it you know i don't get it
you know and then now the narrative you
know brian ortega
definitely a bigger star bigger fight in
the efc he gets in the press conference
goes sorry guys i'm sorry this happened
i can't believe this happened hopefully
i don't have to have shoulder surgery
and was like ah it's such a shame that
main event such a shame meanwhile i'm in
fort wayne indiana going
yeah here i i don't know i know izzy his
wrestling coach i should call him dude
while he's not dude tell [ __ ] get on
any mike he can say that was a
submission win
demand a title shot
now you don't do that do you see that
now that there even dave is like
dan's like it's not what we're hoping
for like
you got to finish a submission win over
brad ortega this is insane
what's the narrative uh brian blew out a
shoulder man main event such a shame
that happened like that
if i mean i hear i'm like running back i
just submit you dude
imagine if i needed to meet you i would
have knocked you out i was winning on
the feet
i found my air i was dominating dude had
the speed advantage
striking an advantage you took me down i
submitted you what do you want to do run
it back for what what do you want to run
back i'm moving on i'm moving on to the
champ win another fight then we'll talk
nope yeah whatever you want to do man
can really happen to your shoulder it's
such a shame it's such a i wish you your
shoulder didn't blow out for me
submitting you
and now you're like and you know
volcanos he's gonna have surgery i think
on his hand he's out with a broken thumb
or whatever the [ __ ] it is so he's out
for a little bit so now they're talking
about an intern title
between him and josh emmett which
i love for josh emmett
we love josh emmett here he's you know
shop show alumni nice guy in the world
um best case for josh emmett couldn't be
a better case if you're josh emmett fan
you're foaming at the dick right now
couldn't be a better situation there's
no clear-cut winner because he ate yair
and take advantage of the situation
right after he submitted brian ortega
and
you know it's up in the air boko nazis
out now so it's like they're not going
to wait that long they owe josh amber
the title shot we all know this so dan's
been like i'm down for an intern belt
and i i'm also one of the few who i
don't mind intern belts the more belts
the merrier make more divisions make
more stars give out more belts the
fighters have more leverage give all the
belts to everybody i like them um so now
you're probably at josh emmett versus
yara rodriguez
unfortunately for brian ortega again who
i absolutely love so be cool uh for for
brian ortega
you know if your shoulder is that big of
a problem it's gonna be you know you're
the issue is is you know he has some
miles on him he's like the nfl running
back nfl running backs have you know
four to six years max if they're
badasses because they're so beat up
that's brian ortega is a nfl running
back he's taking so much punishment he's
known to take shots he's known to give
you great fights when he got to a
certain level his toughness which we all
love
and it gets him through some you know
amazing uh performances but that comes
with a cosmet so now he's lost three out
of four
he's lost three out of four he lost to
max holloway very bad he beat chan
seung-jong you know but think about this
he takes the ufc by storm right he comes
out and he goes one two three four five
six
six
freaking finishes
six fight win streak ko is freaking
frankie edgar in uh you know at the end
of the first round submits cup swanson
you know submits clay guida
you know with that knee uh bloat submits
diego brando black belt with a t his
signature t city everyone lets bryant he
has the long flown here blue eyes big
dick killing it
killing it t city's the man
here's max holloway
he is destroyed
he is destroyed yeah
he takes two years off
two years
right under two years
about about 10 months he takes 10 months
off they give him the korean zombie
he's not young
he's got some miles on him as well
he beats the [ __ ] our korean zombie cool
everyone see me doing that these days
they go you're ready for a title shot
here's volkanovsky
well i see kind of beats his ass he got
him in those submissions close one to
win to be to finish volkolowski outside
those movements that wasn't a very
competitive fight he ate some big shots
but he's so [ __ ] tough
then they go
all right here's yair rodriguez and he
gets submitted
and that was also after another
year layoff
you know
he's just not he it's it's it's if
you're brian t it's tough because these
long layoffs man the division has to
move on and there's killers in the
division
so you know you lost three out of four
i would say got submitted um
and this isn't you know usually anybody
who i have a close relationship with and
i've told you guys since the jump i'm
super biased
but this is to me is
[ __ ] clear as day that was a [ __ ]
submission win for yaya rodriguez easy
easy work anybody who knows jiu-jitsu
knows that's a submission
clear as day but they don't take
advantage dc gave him the mic
super
humble and which is great i love that
i actually prefer that than trash talk
but you have to have some confidence and
call out the champ
now nobody's talking about it now you're
fighting you know emmett for uh interim
title shot nobody's talking about it
it's a bummer um
yeah so if there's a broken arm that'd
be that'd be considered submission right
like an armbar break it yeah because
most the mma committee is not familiar
or especially the casuals aren't
familiar with the positioning
of that arm bar setup and the pressure
on the on the shoulder yeah
it's that initial clamp down and the
torque that's what happens shoulder and
then if it wasn't bad if there wasn't
pressure why did brian ortega pull out
why was he defending if it wasn't a
submission attempt why would he even
attempt to pull out and blow his
shoulder out
there's no pressure if he's comfortable
why not just sit in it
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] torque on
the shoulder man blew his [ __ ]
shoulder out ended the fight yeah
clears day
you know
so shout out to ya rodriguez uh
hopefully brian take your heels up
hopefully doesn't need surgery once
those shoulders pop out that easy it
gets dicey
you know and some miles on him but
phenomenal fighter
one of the best
you know i'm sure he has a big future
and he'll heal up that shoulder and be
back and get a big fight
but if he has uh surgery you'll get at
least another your layoff damn
it's a bummer
let's take another little break
i'm in san diego this thursday friday
saturday take it to thickboy.com san
diego see you soon
now listen
y'all need to take care of yourself man
you gotta
it all starts up here starts in the
brain if your brain's not right you
don't feel good the body's not right you
got to take care of your brain man and
that's where my friends that better help
that's right better help got you covered
man it's online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat on only
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to i think you should if you're up for
it it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours 48
hours i have a therapist it's
life-changing you're talking to real
licensed professionals to help you
navigate this crazy world that we're in
maybe it's stress as a dad a husband
whatever it is work you got to talk to
professional help you untangle all this
craziness we go through anxiety whatever
it is they're going to help you with it
man but you need a professional and
that's why my friends have better help
got you covered and you guys get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelp.com
you know a lot of y'all started off this
summer with some fitness goals you're
like man i need a six pack and they tone
up these shoulders i need to get a chest
i get this bird chest and you don't know
what you would need to do to get there
and reach those goals like i'll just go
to the gym and look up online how to get
swole and ripped i'm too thick
well guess what your boy's here to save
the day
because fit bod fit bond are you kidding
me man fit bod is a smart workout app it
gives you custom tailored workouts just
for you to keep the burn going all
summer long whenever you're ready to go
alright whenever you're ready to go it's
there for you man it's there for you you
can do it wherever if you're on the road
if you're in a hotel this app is
designed for you it's your own personal
trainer on your cell phone imagine that
how much would you pay to have a trainer
make a custom plan just for you work out
to work out that's what fitbot does for
you man you set your goals right and
then as you're going maybe you're going
too fast you're gaining momentum it's
going to change customized just for you
fitbod smart workout app creates a
custom dynamic program based on your
goals not every joe schmoes your goals
based off your experience and the
equipment that's available to you
alright their algorithm uses data and
analytics to build your best next
workout and maximize results this just
isn't random it's custom for you to get
to shred city one-way ticket fit bot get
there alright crush your summer fitness
goals stop messing around just guessing
if you're doing the right thing take all
the guesswork out because fitbot got you
covered all right they're personalized
workouts that are built just for you
it's to help you improve and reach your
fitness goals get 25 off your
subscription or try out the app for free
when you sign up now at fitbo dot me
slash shop s-h-a-u-b that's 25 off your
subscription or try it free at fit bod
dot m-e-slash shop
all right jim what do you got buddy uh
real quick ryan garcia also fought over
the weekend i didn't see the knockout i
know you got a knockout yeah ryan
garcia's uh kind of this new wave he's
also not as active and he will pull out
of fights um and again i don't know how
bad his mental health is
but uh you know ryan garcia is a guy
someone asked me this uh i forget where
i was at maybe i was at the hollywood
improv some fangirls
uh hey man is ryan garcia as good as
they say is or is he just
famous because he's so big on social
media it's a combination of both he has
all the skills
and he's also very famous he's like
justin bieber if justin bieber could
[ __ ] box his ass off he looks good
talks well huge on social media
um
you know and there's this new wave and
i'm not right or wrong where he'll pull
out of fights or take long breaks
because mental health
i don't know what he struggles with i've
been on his podcast um he's been on ours
you know i've talked to him the nicest
kid ever
such a talent
you know the mental health thing it's
tough
stuff so when he does fight it's it's
tough to
it's tough to go all in on him because
you know he could pull out of a fight
you know if
is the mental health thing if the if
there's a lot of pressure on him does
that cosmet like what exactly is
triggering these
horrible mental health um kind of issues
for him i don't know
anxiety has opened up about priest month
we run his battle with anxiety mental
health
in fact his mental health battle got so
bad that the southern california had to
pull out of his uh july
uh fight last year
yeah you know he talks about on his own
and um
he's so talented man
he's so talented oh he used to help that
he's the anxiety though that's part of
the gig
you know
it's part of the gig
and uh
he called out uh uh i think um
uh devin haney too which
i don't know who's gonna beat devin
haney i you know you look at ryan garcia
and the speed and the power that he has
um danny
you know
haney i think would uh probably win that
fight via jab boring decision
his jab's the best i've i've seen in i
don't know how long you know by since
george foreman
the kids so [ __ ] technical it's
insane
you know so we'll see if that happens
but if he struggles with anxiety you
know
doesn't mean like anxiety going into
that fight
yeah i think he called out gervanti too
which would be crazy
yeah but those are the fights that we
want to see those are the fights that
need to be done
um it's just with ryan you just don't
you know it's it's tough and i hopefully
figures it out cause he's fun to watch
man super fast
oh my yeah you guys would know me i mean
if you're not boxing it you'd see you
see him all over social media he punches
you know francis ingato in the stomach
that's the thing
you go on a show he punches in the
stomach i want to show via zoom so i
think you punch in the stomach that was
doing would you let him know if you were
actually in the studio yeah sure i don't
give a [ __ ]
uh this is probably the biggest news oh
this is fantastic charles oliveira is
not making ufc 280 for the vacant title
and we recently just had uh michael
chandler on food truck which is next
week
and he would say you know he's in an
interesting position i can't call him
cash cow and he kind of gets shy like
you tell them that
and i said you know you're the only guy
i know who they're talking about
fighting
conor
and nate diaz and both of them are down
for the fight and i think ufc is going
to do one of those if not both of them
and then he goes it's tough it's like do
you take those money fights and build
your name or my goal is to be champion
and the only way to be champion you know
is i'm not gonna beat those guys and get
a title shot so the quickest path for me
is to fight islam makachev beat him they
can't deny me another shot even if
charles is the champion it doesn't
matter if i beat islam who's the
boogeyman of the division i get a title
shot so he's like i'm trying to figure
that out
figure it out
no you fight nate and connor make all
the money he's a new dad again so he has
two kids
make all the [ __ ] money take all
their fan base take all the fame
beat both of them and then go for the
title shot that's the move dude i don't
know who's managers but there you go
but they know this
i'm not reinventing the wheel here this
is an easy path so when this fight got
announced i text chandler on saturday go
perfect means you're getting the money
fight you need i hate you want to go for
islam let charl let's find out how good
islam is let charles be the first one to
test the waters you don't want to be the
guy that does it we don't know on islam
right now we don't know
we know what he's
been capable of so far but you know his
biggest test against daryus theory she's
like snapped his [ __ ] ankle so we we
don't know where islam is at let charles
let's let's find out against trump we'll
find out against charles we'll find out
yeah great fight phenomenal yeah
and here are the opening odds
kind of crazy
minus 255 you know
yeah charles oliver is a the champ who's
the champ what are we doing everyone
knows he's the real champ so the champ
is that two plus 215. so that means you
bet 100 you win 215
um to break even you bet 215 to win 215.
so
i'm sorry to win 100. so
um
you know a lot of these times when vegas
does these odds they just want to get
your money they're trying to get you to
put more money on charles oliveira not a
terrible bet on charles de la bear
because the verdict is still out on
makchev now
um you know anybody who trains with mike
jeff tells me how [ __ ] talented he is
everybody i've heard it from everybody
so we'll see we'll find out
what do you think ted
no i think it's a great fight
you betting on charles oliveira i feel
like if it does go down charles has
enough submission skills to do something
but mock chef seems super super strong
so i don't know
yeah he's like the anti-jitsu guy you
know with that dagger standing combat uh
you know master of sport black belt so i
think it's a great matchup though
overall oh god it couldn't be a better
match i love it i'm all about it yeah
and uh volkanovsky he's been talking
about going up to 155 so he would want
the winner
of that fight
he's me out for a little bit then you
got you know you have an interim
champion
at 45 between emmett and yahya rodriguez
uh if i'm volcano c2 you know unless
yaya like blows the [ __ ] doors off of
emmett there's not a ton there as far as
uh super stardom
so
you know again we're going to find out a
lot about islam in this fight um you
know if charles were to beat him him
versus volcanos he's fantastic yeah
i don't like the islam fight for him
just based off what i've seen islam so
far even though he has been battle
tested um but the charles oliveira
volklanovsky fight makes all the sense
especially volkkanovsky
all right um
so nate diaz was on mma hour and he said
that the ufc is not offering them fights
all right
somebody's lying here yeah dana says
we're offering fights and danny goes we
can't hold anybody hostage because
my job is to offer fights it's their job
to take him if i don't offer him fights
yes pam they have to pant yeah or let
him go
so anyways that's what he said here he
says a lot of [ __ ] like
nate right now is playing the game
you know his fan base eats it up i look
at you know what
he say i want francis or izzy
those are the only viable options
yeah i don't know at this point it's
like
you know
yeah and uh jake paul also chimed in do
you the turd white degrades the ideas to
the media and then and private gets on
his knees and begs nate to stay so they
can try to revive conor mcgregor get on
your knees and beg you old [ __ ]
so he says in the last nine months i've
been offered zero fights i've asked for
five legitimate opponents yeah i'm
surprised you shouldn't give michael
chandler chandler's down nate's down
that's what i think so i don't know
what's going on in the bat in the in the
in the background there i don't know
i would assume the ufc's offered him
fights yeah that's what i would lean
towards and nate's also saying that
they're trying to get him to sign
another contract so he doesn't want to
do now to nate's defense they could be
offering fights and like hey the only
way you fight hamzot is if you find
another six yeah nate's like nine not
doing that
or they're saying hey we have a match up
for you but you gotta resign and he's
like no just give me the one fight i'm
out so i
i bet you there's dana's story nate's
story than the truth it's somewhere in
the middle uh you know somebody's lying
100 percent
and this is just dana white calling jake
paul a paper pay-per-view turd
i get what he's saying he goes wait hold
on
you're fighting a guy who's coming off a
loss yeah why wouldn't you fight tommy
uh morrison jr who beat the guy you're
coming off a win yeah that's what he
said yeah
and he calls
stephen steven espinoza a weasel thing
yeah he hates him yeah
and then i love this dangerous i know
you guys like to ask me stupid [ __ ] but
this is not what i do i'm at the point
all this stuff going back and forth it's
silly for me to even [ __ ] talk about
yeah
all right so this is interesting too
kamar osman says after the leon edward
edwards fight william wins i saw this i
don't get it he's so small yeah jumping
two divisions right
five yeah
but that's what he wants
i i like him versus yuri it's like what
i know and that's him next to yon i mean
he's not that small
god that [ __ ] vest is lit
that then just all
skin underneath is sick dude you know
give a body you have to have to pull
that out he's freaking one of the best
bodies i mean there look at him
his lower body is what's not light
heavyweight his lower body is
you know lightweight 155.
oh yeah that guy trying to get the
action in the back
yeah i mean that match-up's not like
crazy and uh john's a big 205
really big
yeah i wonder if the power would be an
issue young's power but then the speed
cardio the movement of camaro you know
but i
you know i don't get it
jumping up two weight classes yeah
i wonder if you have seen me down to do
that
and his he has like i'd love to see him
try a horrible night yeah world war one
he has one or two fights left
and this is after leon edwards mind you
yeah which is just
first which is very tough yeah
uh so you know how
uh yuri prahashka called out glover
taksera for his next fight
uh this is uh jan blockovich
responding to him yawn is the biggest
challenge your words respect you champa
the samurai code was not upheld
and then with glover it's a matter of
honor dude to show pure fight this is
more than a challenge
i mean chaos at best like do you call it
a 40 whatever he is five 22 year old
that's not the move i'm a little bit on
that's already one you've already won i
know it wasn't your best performance
when i came out and said the reason i
was defy the knights because they both
had shitty knights
i think gary beats him it's his easiest
fight that's what yuri's doing you want
the biggest name uh easiest fight
possible that's what yuri's doing jon's
the tougher fight yeah and i want to see
the young one way more me too what do
you got chin what else we got
so daniel cormier was doing like a
twitter
interview with monster energy and then
he was talking about if he did come back
he wouldn't go back to heavyweight
because
he lost there but he still he vacated
the light heavyweight belt so he would
actually
do light heavyweight if he ever returned
and then he says right here
hey dana you think i could fight yuri
for the title i did anything but year
for a title
yeah yeah that's a good matchup for like
light heavyweight now is the time when
dc would absolutely dominate or like a a
vintage gustsfin who fights this
saturday they would dominate
yeah
so he says if it ever happens it better
happens soon i'm 44 years old then he
says randy couture won the championship
at 45 so it's not impossible i dig it
i wish they would
if daniel came back but the ufc is like
you know you're just gonna win the title
fight once and dip out yeah it just
screws the entire division yeah
and just makes everyone look bad
i'd love that for dc though
yeah check this out so the warrior movie
they're gonna do a tv series and daniel
cormier's gonna be in it oh sick yeah
and this is what he wrote on his i came
from lafayette louisiana to bring lights
of dock done now i take on hollywood i
teased a while back but not the reality
thanks to paramount plus and lionsgate
truly honored excited for this next
chapter in my life good for dc killing
it dude these boys are crushing it yeah
um so darren so
at first you know he had to pull out the
hermansen fight
it was an undisclosed injury but then it
turns out it was uh his knee like he has
issues with his knees how bad
pretty bad but it's just so frustrating
at this point my career till said an
interview with block asset
i'm happy for the way english mma is
going to see all these up and comers
aspinal pimlet muhammad all these guys
happy to see them in the position
they're in but it's so [ __ ]
frustrating for me at some same time
because i know my potential i'm not down
anyone but i'm the [ __ ] best out
there and i know that in the training
room hmm
he's talking about practice
doesn't matter
uh it's just such a [ __ ] impressive
time for me at the moment because listen
trolls don't bother me but it's just
these [ __ ] comments and all these
even fires like oh he pulled out i'm
like mate come to the gym and i'll
[ __ ] take you out
talk about practice
see me in the octagon
it's the only place that matters i'm
gonna [ __ ] what you can do in practice
you know
uh it's just so frustrating it really is
i'm gonna [ __ ] little play yeah it's
tough you know you know you hope like
his career's been tough
yeah his career and then parts of his
life yeah tough you know hopefully he
figures out he does have
a lot of talent and you know
he's entertaining him yeah he's
entertaining and
it's a bummer to see man but you know
unfortunately the story's not going his
movie's not going great right not right
now
wish him the best though
all right so frankie edgar is saying
that he wants one more fight than to
retire so he wants someone that's in new
york city i think he's talking about uh
he'd love to fight down with cruz i'd be
all about that but dominic cruz fighting
our boy cheeto so even in win lose or
draw crews should take that fight it's
frankie yeager yeah
yeah
so just one more
i bet they give it to him i don't know
if it's gonna be cruz but they give it
to him
all right so the espn
like it's best fighter list of the
fighter list came out
the uh mid-year awards so the best male
and female fighters here you go
apparently this one says it's a tie
between charles oliveira and volksway
but then other articles are saying it
was actually charlotteville charles
oliveira
that one best male fighter
i would give to volkanovsky
i'd say both yeah and best women's
whaley's
good for her
most improved kevin holland interesting
and this is pretty cool
jack de la madeleine
best rookie little australian getting
some action best mission yuri versus
glover
um
i guess because the way it happened
okay
best knockout channeler tony ferguson
for sure definitely and that's the best
picture i know the other one was the
best one right yes face was like the
spartan kick man
yeah
best fight glover tech sarah yuri you
say because there are they're they're
the worst had bad guys yeah
best event you agreed on this right by
far you see london march 19th that's a
great fight yeah this weekend's card is
[ __ ] stacked too best on the mic
moment chandler after defeating tony
virginia that was great
oh that was it that's cool yep
and this is just funny so half of his
eve you know he broke his nose versus
rda
so he had to get surgery so justin got
surgery and that's why he's he's saying
it's perfect for them to fight oh it is
that's a phenomenal [ __ ] fight oh my
god please make it happen yeah and
fazee's coming out for a reason is
his best match up to get to the title
shot so you guys are grapplers badass
striking matches oh my god
all right this sucks espn plus it's got
it's going from 699 to 999 per month in
august
three dollars i don't know who's running
disney these days but just doing an
awful job disney said inflation no doubt
9.99
yeah and then let's also make the
pay-per-views more expensive
annual plan from 69 to 99. that's ins
that's a huge huge ass jump
but whatever gotta do it 43 increase
yeah i mean you know mm-hmm 9.99 just
don't buy a few starbucks in a week and
it makes up for it or just don't buy one
there's no drink under three dollars i
know it's expensive there
i thought this was funny this is sean
strickland
[Music]
i'm here with my boy diego right and i
was like after this fight i'm gonna buy
me a [ __ ] hellcat 700 horsepower all
the great car but then
[Laughter]
the guy's all god damn it
[Music]
[ __ ] you all that's hilarious hilarious
and let's see oh this is just training i
don't know if has this anything like
this ever happened to your training
oh
no absolutely not
so but that is how winkle john lost his
eye yeah well i think it was i forget
what fighter did it i don't think it was
holly holm i forget who was doing it
but uh he was holding mitts and they
missed and hit his eye and cut his eye
that's how he lost his eye yeah i heard
it was like a like a long toenail to you
which is gross
um this is just another weird one
so connor was in ibiza for someone's
birthday i think it was his birthday
actually
and then someone threw a hat at him okay
i wonder what the hat was alright but do
you remember back in the day
cats and gano
if this loads up what the hat was that
pissed him off i mean someone just threw
hats like no but i but i think the
reason he was pissed is because it was
uh
wait why are you showing me this
oh he doesn't have to go and he slips it
perfectly boom boom yeah great this
happened a while though um yeah i wonder
what the hat was that that triggered him
was it i mean just someone throwing a
hat at you i don't think so there had to
be someone to hack he looked down at
them he was pissed off yeah he was
pissed
did did he want him to sign the hat or
just toss him out you know what i'm
saying yeah i don't know i was pretty
upset he did he stomped on it
and i think that's right
yeah uh what time does fight card start
early
12 p.m pacific yes your boy's gonna see
it saturday morning i'll be watching us
in san diego
from the airbnb in san diego because i'm
on tour this thursday friday saturday in
san diego california the life factory
downtown san diego come get you some uh
wednesday night once you're only 10 p.m
anthony jesselnick trevor wallace eric
griffin very special guest and myself 10
p.m show at the hollywood improv then
baltimore's august 4th through the 6th
chicago one night theater show august 26
at the den theater in chicago then i'm
in appleton wisconsin just announced
ontario california the ontario improv in
ontario california september
15-17 then i end september in boston
which i can't wait but san diego you are
up this thursday friday saturday
saturday morning i will be watching ufc
london there ain't nothing like a london
card especially when you got the fifth
beetle paddy pimlin on the most famous
man in liverpool
freaking food truck alumni the boys
killing it is his toughest toughest
matchup yet against jordan levitt
um and i think your boy patty gets it
done i'll pick it uh
i think it's done in the first round via
uh kind of
flashy ko i think a lot of people think
he's gonna submit him i think he gets it
done with a flying knee or some crazy
[ __ ] it's patty pamela for god's sakes
he's a special character and they're
jordan he's the the sugar in the tank
guy yeah yeah yeah sweet love
jordan levitt sweet low uh but the
card's fantastic uh it kicks off with uh
paul craig paul craig
paul craig vulcan owes demerit vulcan's
following some tough times
i do worry about his confidence a little
bit i would take paul craig via
submission that's nothing new there
molly the meatball mccain
uh versus hannah goldie i will take
molly uh this one's this next one's
interesting you have krylov versus
alexander gus finn um i know krylov is
the favorite here i like gus finn maybe
because i have a sweet spot for the guy
who's training with him he's a [ __ ]
monster
um if he was born on any other year
uh you know i'll give a five year grace
period there he'd be your multi-time
light heavyweight champion if there
weren't guys like dc and jon jones
around when he was in his prime but here
he is now so you know this is all
predicated off if you want to put your
money on a guy
um you don't know where he's at mentally
if he wants to be there he could win the
fight if he doesn't it's gonna get ugly
krylov's a [ __ ] monster uh but i'll
take justin anyways uh paddy pimlet
jordan uh levitt
you know tough fight for jordan big name
fight but you're in his backyard uh
patty pamela you could just have him on
the card he'd sell this [ __ ] out uh pat
patty's gonna show out continue the uh
the hype train the liverpool height
train i'll take paddy pimlet via
ko in the first round uh this next one's
in string uh you know you got jack
hermansen versus chris curtis
um it's even money i think it's minus
110 on each guy chris curtis obviously
short notice fight because darren till
pulled out i'd love to uh see darren
till versus jack kermanson uh but we're
not getting it so they call up chris
curtis
um they're right there in the rankings i
think it's like eight nine i'll take her
manson uh
via uh submission late round submission
uh if he can get him down i think he he
gets it done and gets the submission
going the main event this is what i want
to talk about so the main event remember
um you know after tom maskeball's last
win against volkov which was phenomenal
[ __ ] victory
um
and you also had tai tuavasa get a big
win too over uh derrick lewis and i said
we're gonna find out who the ufc wants
to be champs what's interesting because
efc went let's just give uh tom and uh
taito vasa the worst matchups possible
so
you know tom's officially undefeated in
the ufc speeds his advantage he's always
been the better athlete this is the
first time he's not the better athlete
um
you know
that's when i was on the feed in the ufc
is what i mean he has two losses outside
the ufc which i don't care about he's on
a feed in the ufc and he's uh you know
three tkos two submissions he's
finishing everybody he finished freaking
volklav he finished ontariolovski which
is impossible to do
he's had uh what five fights in the ufc
and four of them are performance of the
knights
um
you know
london the uk in general could use uh
heavyweight champ as their face of
mixed martial arts right now it's patty
pimlet it really is he's he's bigger
than his record shows and uh he's bigger
than his experience i think he'll get
there and i think that like i told you i
think his training continues to
steamroll on over jordan levitt um that
being said you know this is the first
fight tom small who
is 100 percent as far as takedown
defense goes
i will bet
anybody that wants to bet curtis blades
takes tom down i will guarantee you
curtis blades takes tom asmalt down
tom is the black belt on the ground like
i said a lot of tom's victories have
come from a speed advantage
and
he's fought decent wrestling nobody like
curtis blades uh if you've seen what
chris blades did at aleister over him
you'll rethink where you want to put
your money on this fight
cursed blades is an underdog in this
fight
um i'm half british my mom born raised
uh grew up with family with accents [ __ ]
like that i always view
root for the english always chris
blade's training for my former team
i talked to his head coach cody donovan
last week he was telling me how much of
a monster curtis is how much better he
gets every camp
uh i like to make money
you know the one thing i like more than
being english is making money uh curtis
blaise being an underdog is insulting i
know it's in tom askewell's backyard i
know tom's a very good athlete curtis
blades right now in current day is a
better mixed martial artist than tom
aspinall in no facet should tom asmal be
the favorite in this fight
where they have matt
plus one fifteen tom aston minus one
thirty five now you're assuming tom
aspinall's takedown defense is as good
as everyone thinks it is and you're
assuming tom aspinall can uh tko him
either early or as the fight uh gets
into the later rounds
curtis blights has been battle tested
there's not too many guys who can beat
him not name francis and gano um
he's as tough as they come man you know
he is that he had the fight against
derek lewis but he's fought strikers
before i don't know if he's fought as
well as around
you know temp the best thing about tom
aspinall he's a very good athlete he's
big
he's actually taller than kurdish blades
clearly has better striking
i don't know if he's as powerful as
curtis blades when it comes to straight
ko power um and kurdish blaze is going
to get better and because curtis blades
he's starting to put together the
striking with the wrestling now curtis
blades his nickname is blades for a
reason because his elbow is his ground
and pound and also he rhymes with his
last name um but
you know curtis blade's takedown once he
does get you down it's
you you don't have to worry about
submissions you have to worry about your
face getting beaten to a pulp
i just can't say confidently that tom
asmaral not only i guarantee you it's
stagnant guarantee you unless there's a
mazda doll badasser moment where the
flying knee knocks him out early on i
would bet my bottom dollar he gets taken
down what does he do off of his back
in most cases
unfortunately if you're fighting kurdish
blades when you get taken down it's a
world of problems
you know tom assenal is a black belt is
his guard black belt level i don't i
don't know it's gonna be tough to submit
um curtis blades while you're getting
beat in the face with elbows and ground
and pound to pull off a triangle or a um
arm bar
you know so i just look at this fight 25
minutes curtis plays an underdog
i can't emphasize enough how much curse
blaze doesn't give a [ __ ] about flying
out to london to be the main event does
not care kid is a savage
i i couldn't believe he's an underdog i
i in my head i'm like i can't think of a
worse matchup for tom aspinall than
curtis literally in
if there's a [ __ ] 500 heavyweights in
this world there could not be a
stylistically worse matchup than curtis
blades for tom aspinall
what he does is exactly what tom
aspinall doesn't do great
now he does everything
very [ __ ] well
that's why they're pushing them here the
winner of this right there for kyle
title contentions
i just if i'm the ufc i think it kind of
[ __ ] tom asmull and i'm a massive tom
fan
massive i'm on his [ __ ] train i
[ __ ] hate this fight for him hate it
i don't think he wins
i hate to say it
can't think of worse matchup i would
much rather you put tom vs tie to avasa
clearly it's not going to the judges
clearly somebody gets knocked out then
sell that guy as the next champ and then
tom versus francis is a better matchup
for him tom versus derrick lewis is a
better matchup for him tom versus
[ __ ] uh uh uh um what's his what's
his name the the [ __ ] monster so
athletic
um oh surrogate sarah
much better matchup
i'll give you
a thousand ways tom aspinall can beat
francis and cyril gone stipe taitu avasa
derek lewis
it's going to be very tough for him to
beat curtis blades
they are not doing any favors in his
hometown i can't emphasize enough how
awful a match-up this is for tom and it
pisses me off
tom first tattoo avasa um it's a great
fight curtis tied to avasta
but if you look at tai tuavasa and
sirogan you're like
if thailand's this thing's over
for tom against curtis chris has been
there with [ __ ]
tom
monsters
is not he doesn't have the power
like a uh francis gano derrick lewis
where if you make one mistake it's over
he's not that guy he now
as far as
technique wise goes i would say he's
more technical than francis i'd say he's
more technical on the feet than stipe
he's not as technical cyril gone he's
more technical and tied to avasa more
technical than derrick lewis um you know
he had that big win over
alexander volkov which is huge
but he didn't have to worry about the
takedown really against volkov he's
gonna be worried the entire time about a
takedown of curtis blades if he gets
taken down
it's a [ __ ] nightmare i know he's a
black belt i get all that forget about
your black belt curtis blades eat your
black belt for [ __ ] breakfast
i hate this fight for tom
if he pulls it off
dude you won't
i will [ __ ] tell you right now if he
beats curtis blades
him the chance of him being champion are
highly likely
this is by far his biggest test he
should look at this like a championship
fight because if you beat curtis blades
in your hometown they're going to be a
worse matchup for you you beat him you
finish curtis blades we're going [ __ ]
sizzler i don't have sizzlers around in
london we're going fishing chips or
where the [ __ ] you want to eat
awful matchup for him
if he gets it done hats off to him tough
fight
i'll take curtis blaze i'll put my mind
cursed blades
hate saying that hate saying that hate
these two are fighting hate the ufc
decided to do cyril gone tai tuva ta tai
tu avasa curtis blade's tom asmall
should been the opposite should bring
curtis blades
sarah gone who have both had
opportunities to fight for the title and
haven't got it done
but curtis blades
probably beats frickin cyril gone
you know is wrestling so [ __ ] good
he's a nightmare to deal with he's only
getting better
so have them fight and then have tom and
tai two of us will fight that's a
phenomenal fight that's such a fun fight
tied to avasta right now in england
doing shoes with the brits it's easy
but something's going on behind the
scenes where they don't want ty or tom
to come out on top
they gave him both the worst matchups
[ __ ] possible
which as far as marketing goes makes no
sense you're telling me if tom asman was
your [ __ ] heavyweight champion you
can't market that you're telling me a
guy tied to avasa who's basically jack
black from australia but he has knockout
power we can't market that
over curtis blades
where he would be the face of the
heavyweight division if he didn't lose
you know those francis and derek lewis
fights but
outside that not the biggest personality
on there doesn't mind just taking it
down making it boring he'll tell you
that too he before fights tonight i'll
tell you right now it's gonna be a
boring fight i'm taking him down making
it boring gonna win the fight ufc hates
that sarigan we saw that
you know he
technical you know he's very technical
doesn't mind winning on the feet boring
decision
you could you're investing those guys
that's what they're doing they're
investing in those guys
it makes no [ __ ] sense i hate they
did this to tom i hate this dude tied to
ivasa i hope both of them win the chance
of both them winning is not good
if they do dude hats off then we're
going to get that fight and i'll be so
happy that's the nature of the sport i
think ufc made a terrible mistake good
luck tom astronaut i'm rooting for you
buddy uh can't wait for this card can't
wait to perform in san diego it's gonna
be a fun weekend i will see you at the
hollywood improv wednesday night 10 p.m
show i will see you in san diego this
thursday friday saturday and that's it
man tickets at thinkboy.com love you
guys enjoy the fights ufc london there
ain't nothing like your london card
uh that's it be nice to each other stay
safe love you i'm out
you